in this short video we would quickly
look at vermin b2 or otherwise known as
a 5-11 so vitamin b2 arrival 11 has two
distinct structure one is the die metal
I saw a log selling ring that you can
see here and the deer ibotta rabbit all
which is a sugar moiety now vermin b2 is
found in mostly beef liver or any other
kind of animal liver whole milk fresh
leafy vegetables such as spinach and
lettuce legumes and many kind of cereals
now the active form of riboflavin is
either fmm or fa d so flavin
mononucleotide or flavin adenine
dinucleotide so first la ma khyen ales
converts riboflavin to FMN then this is
just a modification as it's a kindness
enzyme it's just adding a phosphate
group to the right of Lebanon moiety and
forming it an effeminate later on there
is a fraidy synthase which converts FMN
into fa d remember that f MN and f 8d
are the formats of the coenzyme for
several metabolic processes most of
important metabolic processes are
carbohydrate metabolism and fatty acid
metabolism for the enzymes which use f
MN and fa d as a coenzyme let us take an
example so here we have our F ad which
is the co enzyme of this particular
enzyme forget about the name for now but
it works like an electron acceptor or a
hydrogen acceptor so what happens is
this F ad which is attached to the
enzyme it would be reacting and after
the reaction it would be reduced to
fadh2 but at the same time it works in
oxidation reaction so the substrate will
be oxidized but the F ad will be reduced
to fadh2 and here you can see the two
hydrogen's which are added into the I
saw allows us in ring
now in cyclic acid cycle one of the
important step is conversion of
succinate to fumarate and this process
is triggered by succinate dehydrogenase
as the name suggests the hydrogenation
reaction and it is triggered by
dehydrogenase and the oxidation step
right now if you look at it in two
details so succinate dehydrogenase
converts succinate into fumarate and at
the same process if ad is reduced to
fadh2 in this in this reaction so now we
can understand how important is the
riboflavin derived F ad for this kind of
glucose metabolism pathway or overall
metabolism now seriously there is very
less deficiency in case of riboflavin
because in intestine there are micro
flora which can really synthesize BT but
many of the pathological conditions of
other vitamin deficiencies like like
pellagra like berry berry these
accompanies with a vitamin b2 deficiency
as well now the major symptoms of the
deficiency is chil OSIS that means are
rash or redness near the lips other kind
of symptoms includes glossitis which
means some pathological alteration of
the tongue because lhasa means tongue
here you can see the tongue become
purple or magenta color and that that is
the clinical manifestation of vitamin b2
deficiency or riboflavin deficiency at
the same time you have circum corneal
vascularity ssin or you have like more
vascular cornea I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give it a
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you